okay
hey guys
yes the title of this video is real this
is not clickbait the darn mess youtube
channel is coming to an end not because
i don't love doing this but because this
incredible eight-year journey has led to
unimaginable opportunities for me that i
just can't turn down however to honor
this relationship and the community that
we've built i've decided to pour every
ounce of creativity combined with a hell
of a lot of planning and developed a
12-part show the final chapter if you
will brought to you by discovery plus in
the show i do everything i've always
wanted to try everything i've never had
the resources or time to attempt
everything that's now been made possible
by discovery plus i really want to go
out with a bang this show will run from
january until july of 2022 and
thereafter i will say goodbye
up until january i'll still be uploading
a few vlogs and seeing sans videos but i
just wanted to make this video for now
as a trailer
for what's to come
[Music]
it's a double rainbow
[Music]
[Music]
and that's a wrap guys well done
good job
yes yes
yes
thank you
other than that thank you so much for
your continual support and don't forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you